to an outsider the excitement for this
man might come as a bit of a surprise
bong bong Marcus is the son of late
Filipino dictator Ferdinand Marcos who
installed a terror regime in the
Philippines in the 1970s and 80s but at
this campaign rally in the capital
Manila people support bong bong spit for
the vice presidency many want him to
carry on his father's legacy
Marco's will be the one to finish 500
kilometers to the north lies the home
province of the Marcos family Ilocos
Norte is their power base here they've
ruled uncontested for decades holding
every important political office and
here they glorify their troubled past in
the family mausoleum late dictator
Ferdinand Marcos has been lying in state
for more than 20 years there's not a
word about his many victims or the 10
billion US dollars the Marcus's are
believed to have embezzled during his
rule here in Batak City and in fact in
the whole region you'll have a hard time
finding someone who doesn't support the
Marcos family the fact that tens of
thousands of Filipinos were detained
tortured and even killed under the
Marcos rule doesn't seem to make people
here doubt their loyalty in the least
for many here the Marcus's are nothing
but good Samaritans
if we approach them and ask for their
help they always help us out they would
give us cash or other things if we need
to go to the hospital they help us with
paying the bill you think Bongbong
Marcos can't be held accountable for
what his father did he is not involved
your mother died he and his siblings
were still very young when all that
happened what these loyalists seem to
forget
Bongbong Marcos already held high
political positions during the last
years of his father's rule back in
Manila
Maria Lao Enriquez and her companions
are less convinced of Bongbong Marcos
innocence they all fell victim to his
father's regime and now they blame the
son for not taking responsibility he
doesn't like to apologize he said I
won't apologize for the crimes that he
did not commit he said that it was his
father if we really wants to help the
Filipino people they should return the
money that they stole from the coffers
of the bong bong Marcus says he wants to
unify the nation but his current
candidacy and the prospect at yet
another Marcos could at some point be in
charge of the country is polarizing
Filipino society